WATCHING.
"AC 360" STARTS RIGHT NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING.
TONIGHT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
MESSAGE TO THE SUPREME COURT,
STAY OUT OF MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS
CASE.
EVER SINCE THE FBI GOT A WARRANT
AND CONDUCTED A COURT-APPROVED
SEARCH, FINDING BOXES OF
DOCUMENTS, INCLUDING HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED ONES THAT DID NOT
BELONG TO HIM, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TRYING TO
SLOW OR STOP THE WHEELS OF
JUSTICE FROM TURNING.
WHICH IS HIS RIGHT, EACH ABOUT
IF IT MEANS TAKING IT ALL THE
WAY TO THE SUPREME COURT, WHICH
HE HAS.
TODAY WAS THE DEADLINE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO MAKE
ITS CASE TO THE SUPREME COURT.
WE'LL HAVE DETAILS ON THEIR
FILING IN A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
HAS NOW ALSO BEEN MAKING NEW
FALSE STATEMENTS ABOUT OTHER
FORMER PRESIDENTS KEEPING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
HE PREVIOUSLY CLAIMED FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA KEPT MILLIONS OF
DOCUMENTS FOR HIMSELF.
NOW IT'S OBAMA AND BILL CLINTON
AND GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
>> GEORGE H.W. BUSH TOOK
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOCUMENT.
TO FORM A BOWLING ALLEY FEESED
TOGETHER WHAT WAS THEN AN OLD
AND BROKEN CHINESE RESTAURANT.
THEY PUT THEM TOGETHER.
AND IT HAD A BROKEN FRONT DOOR
AND BROKEN WINDOWS.
OTHER THAN THAT, IT WAS QUITE
SECURE AND THERE WAS NO
SECURITY.
>> THE DOCUMENTS WERE TAKEN TO
WHAT WAS ONCE A BOWLING ALLEY
AND CHINESE RESTAURANT, BUT IS
NOW A HEAVILY SECURED GOVERNMENT
FACILITY.
TODAY PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT
REPORTS INDICATING OR IMPLY THAT
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS WERE IN
THE POSSESSION OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENTS OR THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES AFTER THEY LEFT
OFFICE OR THAT THE RECORDS WERE
HOUSED IN SUBSTANDARD CONDITIONS
ARE FALSE AND MISLEADING.
DETAILS NOW ON TODAY'S FILING
FROM JESSICA SCHNEIDER WHO JOINS
US FROM WASHINGTON.
WALK US THROUGH THE DOJ'S
RESPONSE.
>> WELL, ANDERSON, THEY HIT ON
TWO MAJOR POINTS.
IN MAKING THE CASE THAT THE
SUPREME COURT SHOULDN'T STEP IN
HERE TO GRANT TRUMP'S EMERGENCY
PETITION, BECAUSE OF COURSE HE
IS ASKING FOR VERY LIMITED
RELIEF HERE.
HE WANTS THE SPECIAL MASTER AS
WELL AS HIS LEGAL TEAM TO HAVE
ACCESS TO 100 CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT'S SOMETHING THE 11 CIRCUIT
HAD BLOCKED.
FIRST SAYING THE 11th CIRCUIT
HAD FULL AUTHORITY TO BLOCK
SINCE THEY'RE SENSITIVE TO
NATIONAL SECURITY AND THE
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE HARMED IF
THEY WERE DISTRIBUTED.
AND THEIR SECOND POINT IS ON THE
FLIP SIDE, THEY SAY TRUMP HASN'T
BEEN HARMED AT ALL BY THE COURT
BLOCKING THESE RECORDS.
SO THERE IS REALLY NO BASIS FOR
THE SUPREME COURT TO STEP IN AT
THIS POINT.
THAT'S THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
VIEW.
THEY WANT THE SUPREME COURT TO
STAY OUT OF WHAT HAS BEEN THIS
ONGOING SAGA OVER THESE RECORDS.
>> I ALSO -- THE DOJ WAS
CRITICAL OF JUDGE CANNON WHO HAS
REPEATEDLY SIDED WITH THE TRUMP
LEGAL TEAM IN THE PROCEEDINGS.
>> VERY CRITICAL THROUGHOUT THIS
34-PAGE FILING.
AND THEY REALLY BLASTED HER.
JUST AILEEN CANNON.
THEY BLASTED HER FOR EVEN
APPOINTING THE SPECIAL MASTER IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND HER DECISION
TO GRANT THE SPECIAL MASTER FULL
ACCESS TO THE DOCUMENTS BEFORE
THE 11th CIRCUIT STEPPED IN.
THEY REPEATEDLY CITED THE 11th
CIRCUIT'S DECISION WHERE THE
11th CIRCUIT EVEN CRITICIZED
JUDGE CANNON.
DOJ SAID THIS ABOUT JUDGE
CANNON'S ORDER THAT ALLOWED THE
SPECIAL MASTER TO INITIALLY
REVIEW THE RECORDS.
THEY SAY THE DISTRICT COURT'S
ORDER WAS A SERIOUS AND
UNWARRANTED INTRUSION ON THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH'S AUTHORITY TO
CONTROL THE USE AND DISTRIBUTION
OF EXTRAORDINARILY SENSITIVE
GOVERNMENT RECORDS.
AND THAT, ANDERSON, WILL REALLY
BE A THEME IN WHAT'S THIS
ONGOING APPEAL IN THE 11th
CIRCUIT WHERE THERE IS THIS
PARALLEL CHALLENGE TO AILEEN
CANNON'S DECISION TO EVEN STEP
INTO THIS CASE AND APPOINT A
SPECIAL MASTER IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
ANDERSON?
>> JESSICA SCHNEIDER, APPRECIATE
IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOINING US THE FORMER FEDERAL
JUDGE NANCY GERTNER.
DANIEL GOLDMAN, FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR WHO SERVED AS FORMER
DEMOCRATIC COUNSEL ON THE
PRESIDENT'S FIRST IMPEACHMENT
AND IS CURRENTLY RUNNING AS A
DEMOCRAT IN NEW YORK.
AND PERSPECTIVE FROM ELLIOT
WILLIAMS, WHO SERVED AS DEPUTY
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
JUDGE GERTNER, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
FILING?
DO YOU THINK THEY'LL PREVAIL?
>> THEY SHOULD PREVAIL.
BY RIGHTS THEY SHOULD PREVAIL.
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT THIS
APPEAL THAT IS REMOTELY THE KIND
OF ISSUE THAT THE SUPREME COURT
WOULD GET INVOLVED IN.
ASIDE FROM THE ISSUE OF
AUTHORIZATION AND ASIDE FROM THE
ISSUE OF JURISDICTION, COURTS
DON'T MICROMANAGE SEARCHES LIKE
THIS.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE OTHER
POINT THAT THE OTHER POINT THAT
WAS MADE IN THE DOJ'S FILING IS
THAT IN THE USUAL COURSE, THERE
IS -- DISTRICT COURTS DON'T
INTERVENE IN A CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING UNLESS THERE IS A --
UNLESS THERE IS ACTUALLY AN
INDICTMENT AND CHARGES, AND THEN
THE DEFENDANT CAN COME FORWARD
AND MOVE TO SUPPRESS THE
DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY FROM THE
BEGINNING AND UNWARRANTED FROM
THE BEGINNING.
AND THEY'VE MADE THE POINT.
AND CERTAINLY IF THE SUPREME
COURT INTERVENES, IT WOULD BE
LUNACY.
>> DANIEL, ONE OF THE DOJ'S
ARGUMENTS THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DOESN'T EVEN ATTEMPT
TO EXPLAIN HOW HE WOULD BE
IRREPARABLY INJURED HERE, AND
THAT ALONE IS ENOUGH TO DENY HIS
REQUEST.
IS THAT ACCURATE, DO YOU THINK?
>> YES, OF COURSE THAT'S
ACCURATE.
I THINK WHAT I FIND IN READING
THIS AND BOILING DOWN TO WHAT
TRUMP IS ACTUALLY APPEALING,
WHICH IS NOT EVEN THE ENTIRETY
OF THE 11th CIRCUIT'S ORDER,
BASICALLY, WHAT DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS LAWYERS WANT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
EVIDENCE, AND LOOK AT THE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION THAT THEY
SEIZED FROM MAR-A-LAGO IN PART
SO THAT THEY CAN PREPARE THEIR
DEFENSE AND SO THAT THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO STYMIE THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION BEFORE IT ACTUALLY
RESULTS IN AN INDICTMENT.
THEY'RE NOT ARGUING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SHOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO EXAMINE THE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
JUDGE CANNON RULED THAT
INITIALLY.
THE 11th CIRCUIT SWIFTLY
REJECTED THAT ARGUMENT, AND
TRUMP IS NOT EVEN APPEALING
THAT.
ALL HE WANTS IS FOR THE SPECIAL
MASTER AND HIS OWN ATTORNEYS TO
BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THESE
DOCUMENTS.
BUT HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE
SPECIAL MASTER.
HE JUST WANTS TO BE ABLE TO SEE
WHAT THEY ARE.
>> THE GOVERNMENT IS ARGUING
THAT ALLOWING THAT, THE SPECIAL
MASTER AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS TO LOOK AT
THESE DOCUMENTS WOULD JEOPARDIZE
NATIONAL SECURITY.
ARE THEY EVEN ALLOWED TO LOOK AT
THESE DOCUMENTS?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S COMPLICATED,
ANDERSON, BECAUSE WE'VE NEVER
BEEN IN THIS SITUATION BEFORE.
NOW, LOOK, WHEN DEALING WITH
INFORMATION THAT IS THIS SECURE,
AT LEAST AS WE BELIEVE TO BE
THIS SECURE, THE MERE RISK OF
DISCLOSURE IS ITSELF
SIGNIFICANTLY SORT OF THAT'S THE
HARM, THE THOUGHT THAT IT MIGHT
GET INTO SOMEONE'S HANDS.
SO IT'S NOT AN UNFAIR QUESTION
OR FROM THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO BE SUSPICIOUS OF IT GETTING
INTO ANYONE'S HANDS.
NOW LOOK, JUDGE GEARY WITH HIS
BACKGROUND HAVING BEEN AROUND
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS BEFORE IS
IN AS GOOD A POSITION AS ANYONE
TO REVEAL MATERIALS.
BUT I AGREE WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT THESE ARE
SENSITIVE MATERIAL, AND YOU
OUGHT TO VERY CLOSELY AND VERY
CAREFULLY MANAGE WHO HAS ACCESS
TO THEM.
>> JUDGE, HOW UNUSUAL IT IS THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WENT OUT
OF ITS WAY TO CRITICIZE JUDGE
CANNAN.
SAYING SHE FUNDAMENTALLY ERRED
IN APPOINTING THE SPECIAL MASTER
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THEY ECHOED THE 11th CIRCUIT,
SAYING SHE ABUSED HER
DISCRETION.
>> IS IT UNUSUAL FOR A JUDGE TO
BE CRITICIZED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE?
>> YEAH.
>> NO.
THAT'S NOT PARTICULARLY UNUSUAL.
THEY WANTED TO GO BACK TO FIRST
PREMISES, WHAT I SAID A MOMENT
AGO.
THIS ENTIRE PROCEEDING IS GIVING
TRUMP RIGHTS AND ROUNDS IN THIS
PROCEEDING THAT HE NEVER SHOULD
HAVE HAD TO BEGIN WITH.
AND THAT'S THE POINT THAT THEY
ARE REALLY MAKING.
SHE WENT OUT OF HER WAY TO ALLOW
A PUNITIVE DEFENDANT, SOMEONE
NOT EVEN INDICTED YET TO
INTERVENE OR HAVE THE COURT
INTERVENE IN THIS IN A WAY HE
NEVER WOULD.
THIS IS REALLY A HOUSE OF CARDS.
AND WE GET WRAPPED UP IN THE
LATEST FILING AS IF IT IS
LEGITIMATE.
BUT IT REALLY IS A HOUSE OF
CARDS.
TRUMP HAS NO BASIS, NO
PRIVILEGE, NO EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, NO ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE TO CHALLENGE HIS
HAVING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN
HIS BEACH HOUSE, END OF
DISCUSSION.
WHAT HE IS DOING, THEY JUST KIND
OF KEEP THINGS GOING, LIKE A
HOUSE OF CARDS.
>> DANIEL, THERE WAS THIS
REPORTING BY "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
HAD TRIED TO USE SOME OF THESE
DOCUMENTS, NEGOTIATING WITH THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES TO GET FBI
RUSSIA DOCUMENTS TO HIM IN
EXCHANGE FOR THEM.
DOES THAT IMPLY THAT HE KNEW
WHAT HE HAD?
>> IT CERTAINLY IMPLIES THAT HE
KNEW HE HAD SOMETHING THAT THE
ARCHIVES WANTED.
IT ALSO JUST GOES TO SHOW HOW
LAWLESS HE IS AND HOW -- WHAT
LITTLE REGARD HE HOLDS THE RULE
OF LAW.
THE FACT THAT HE'S TRYING TO USE
THESE AS A NEGOTIATING PLOY WITH
THE ARCHIVES IS ABSURD.
BUT WHAT IT CALLS TO MIND, WHAT
WAS HE EXPECTING TO DO WITH
THESE DOCUMENTS?
IF HE WANTS TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THE ARCHIVES RELATED TO THESE
DOCUMENTS, WHY DID HE GO TO SUCH
GREAT LENGTHS TO CONCEAL THEM
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
AND IF HE IS SUCH A NEGOTIATOR,
WHAT WAS HE GOING TO DO WITH
THEM?
HOW WAS HE GOING TO USE THEM?
AND I CONTINUE TO JUST BE
HIGHLY, HIGHLY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT HE WOULD DO AND WHAT HE
POTENTIALLY DID DO WITH THESE
DOCUMENTS.
>> JUDGE GERTNER, WHAT DID YOU
MAKE OF THAT "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTING?
>> WELL, I MEAN, IT SHOWS -- I
MEAN, HE WAS USING THESE
DOCUMENTS TRANSACTIONALLY,
RIGHT?
HE WAS GOING TO MAKE A DEAL WITH
IT.
BUT IT ALSO SHOWS HOW
INTENTIONAL THE KEEPING OF THE
DOCUMENTS WERE.
AT THE VERY BEGINNING, IF I
DON'T YOU RECALL, THERE WAS THE
FEELING THIS WAS SWEPT UP IN A
CHAOTIC LEAVE-TAKING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THAT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
CASE.
HE KNEW WHAT HE HAD.
HE KNEW THEM TO BE CLASSIFIED.
AND THE FUNDAMENTAL INGREDIENTS
THEN OF EITHER AN OBSTRUCTION
CHARGE OR AN UNLAWFUL RETENTION
OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS CHARGE
ARE THERE.
AND THAT'S TROUBLING.
>> ELLIOTT, IF THIS DOES NOT GO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S WAY, ARE
THERE ANY OTHER OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO HIS LEGAL TEAM TO
DRAG THIS OUT?
>> LOOK, HE WILL CERTAINLY HAVE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO FILE
APPEALS ALONG THE WAY.
BUT WE SHOULD BE CLEAR,
ANDERSON.
EVEN IF THIS DOES GO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S WAY, NOTHING REALLY
AFFECTS THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY TO WORK WITH THESE
DOCUMENTS AS EVIDENCE, WHICH IS
A BIG STICKING POINT HERE.
THEY WILL STILL BE ABLE TO
PROCEED AND CONDUCT THIS
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE OF HOW
NARROW THIS APPEAL WAS.
LOOK, THE SUPREME COURT DOES NOT
NEED TO TAKE THIS CASE TO BACK
UP JUDGE GERTNER'S POINT FROM
EARLIER IN THIS SEGMENT.
THEY CAN JUST LOOK THE OTHER WAY
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THIS IS
A RELATIVELY SIMPLE AND STRAIGHT
FORWARD LEGAL QUESTION HERE.
BUT AT THE END OF TH